but we're still keeping our eyes on the
situation in Dubai these are live
pictures it's 2154 in Dubai so just over
two hours away from the planned firework
celebrations for all the different
cities up and down the gulf of course
differing reports coming in about the
identity of this building some are
saying it's a residential building but
there are still reports around that it
could also be a hotel now it's not
uncommon for a hotel establishment and
of course residential properties as well
to share the same building of main
concern of course will be to the
authorities in Dubai and of course to
anyone living near there or even living
in that building is that the flames
appear to be engulfing well it looks
like almost all the floors now of that
particular building what we haven't
found out yet is how long the fire has
been burning it does appear to be still
out of control no doubt the dubai fire
services are in attendance at the base
of the building but it does appear that
the fire has gotten away from them at
this stage it's also hard to make out
whether or not the the lights above
those flames are actually part of the
same structure or a structure behind
that one nonetheless reports coming in
at the moment are pretty sketchy to say
the least we have a Downtown Dubai
address at this stage that we're hearing
a people are going on to Twitter sending
out these pictures and saying that their
horrific but there doesn't now one
report suggests this might be what they
called a torch tower in Dubai it's not a
building I familiar with but they say
this different the residence of this
particular building the torch tower our
reporter is saying that they thought the
fire started around the 52nd floor the
fire broke out the torch tower at the
dubai marina early on Saturday morning
has been brought under control
well we're Hillary reports has been
brought under control that certainly
doesn't look like a fire that's being
completely brought under control but the
location we understand now we're hearing
it by with the torch tower near the
marina down on the waterfront which is
very close to the location of course
where the fireworks display a scheduled
for two hours time you're watching Sky
News we've got our eyes on this
we for you